you're a psychopath i'm a professional
i'm invisible that's where i'm going to
be i got heat all over me i'm not
telling you where i am
what are you going to arrest me how do
you people please arrest me
[Applause]
you're under arrest
so why were you looking to get locked up
theodore everyone's trying to kill me
he nearly killed us
what'd you do i did what i had to do
to get to you teddy
and the legendary bob vitic you're a
psychopath
i'm a professional you pissed off the
wrong people
i'm gonna kill you drop that
gun no one kills anyone in here
you say you fell yeah yeah well to
clarify
i shot him in the head and then he took
that little tumble
hola
[Music]
how bad is it are you an idiot teddy
anthony lamb
i'm going by the more friendly and less
formal tonight these days clear off my
contract
no can do this contract is free fire as
there are competing parties
for one theodore moreto bob are we gonna
duel to the death
get me out of here always
and only about teddy
kenny
here they come let's make a deal man i
got a lot of money
there's no deal to be made come on teddy
you know how this goes
i need to know everything all you have
to do is let me blow his head off when i
had the chance
[Music]
i'm coming in there whether you like it
or not yeah
now you see the difference that is a
psychopath
you